Oh
plenty so high levels in the papa
assalammualaikum what I've met you like
we better care to brothers and sisters
welcome to reality 10 on today's topic
we're going to be talking about I am NOT
a virgin this is a topic that's really
sensitive and we're going to cover it
from an angle of the brothers right this
what we're going to cover because as we
know it's a common problem where we get
a lot of messages from our team from
sisters saying look I've done mistakes
in my past I'm scared to get married or
something said I've got married but my
husband made a really big deal out of
this etc etc so that's why we want to
discuss it in detail why men behave like
this why do they make it such a big deal
is it to be like is it something that
needs to be made as a big deal were
gonna get here from from Mohammed Julian
and brother Imran and before I start I
want to please Allah Allah the most
merciful the most trust all praises and
glory belong to him and so before I
start guys please watch the video in
form before you jump to assumptions and
think would be one-sided I was just all
men speak and unfortunately we couldn't
get sister said because it's a topic
that's you know it needs to be a you
know we all need to be higher you know
and we don't want this to be there here
in Shalala so that's what we can get
their perspectives to hope you guys
understand I'm gonna go straight to
brother Julian yeah now brother Julian I
want you to tell me as that person to
yourself yeah would you like like if you
if if a sister came and said look I
haven't passed yet yeah and I was with
two people before or three people yeah
how would you react to that and why
would you react
why do men react whatever it is um to be
honest I don't know how I would react
because it depends on how much I wanna
wanna like put the effort in okay
like if someone would approach me and
would be like listen I have a past and I
wouldn't be like that interested I would
say like maybe it's for the best to just
you go your way I go mine okay
but um I think that if it came to a
point that I that I'm really into
someone yeah then I think I would like
try to LA yeah like look over that you
know like I I think in the beginning I
would like maybe think
about it and mmm like it would okay what
what makes you think about it what makes
you that triggers that you know what I
don't know or not you why this men in
general when they hear this alike hmm I
don't know I think it's it it has
something to do with like a manly ego
okay like knowing that your wife has
been with someone else before you like
sheep build up certain memories that are
I guess theater because women think like
very different than men yeah so they're
such a first is a big yeah that's so it
doesn't make sure it doesn't make it
insecure but it's affects it affects you
because when you're with her maybe she
thinks about like oh yeah okay
yeah me and and you don't use it is a
big fing bore like you know you don't
forget your first inning that's why I
can I kiss you don't we are like do
don't speak against dumb guys don't so
and his girls are like even more
emotional and more attached to memories
so so are you telling me it's the fear
of okay it her thinking about her ex up
okay he was the first one oh he was the
first one and oh I like our relation
well we ever had with him I like that
and that's that's bad is that what fears
you more like is it the fact that she
lost her virginity to him yeah
or is it that she eyesh maybe she
enjoyed it more with him yeah guys like
and you're like am I am I going to like
meet the standards is that is that clubs
why no I won't want to marry what what
makes you trigger that to say you know
what sec to one person before you're not
virgin hmm I don't know it's not like
that I'm not living up to the same
standards as he did yeah but it's more
like I don't want my my wife to think
about another man when I'm like doing
something with her and it doesn't have
to be like sexually but like yeah you
like it
okay I'm gonna go to brother Mohammed
what's your take on this
you heard Julian you heard a bit of what
in rank attorneys is gonna comment that
formal in Shaba what's your take
it's me laughs run on him well what's
been said it's the truth okay I want to
say that first of all okay thank what
you guys are going to talk or what you
guys have been talking about yeah the
fact there's gonna be a plane on your
mind yeah
regardless if you have an issue with her
being a virgin or not yeah this is gonna
pay with your mind yes okay but actually
let me tell you this here a lot of
things play with your mind okay in this
dunya and in this world you'll never get
the best of the best you will never get
ideal circumstances even if she's
virtually you virgin you've got other
problems problems in America okay for me
first personally I care about about how
she is right now because I've been
speaking to this girl then for imagine I
am here speaking for the school for many
reasons yeah I'm just not going to be
able okay like I like your the color of
your job today what let's get it huh
yeah that's not the way it's gonna
happen in it yeah oh there are things in
a carrot that I really like and things
that I say manhandle it across I want to
stand next to her you know camera I want
her to be a the main teacher of my
children okay this was a mother in spur
yeah nothing less yeah okay so if she
did what she did and she's made a
relationship with a loss for Hannah what
the hell I wish I could look upon the
beings upon Allah I am convinced that
there's so much butter caught there I'm
not saying they're gonna be no issues
yeah so so do you you're saying to me I
don't care if she is she is not a virgin
no as long as she sees I've also taken a
lot location whoa would you look for a
key it's not what want to look for in an
innocent I know many reasons yeah and I
think it should be another video about
that is a lot of a pretty another top
usually but what I looking insist is it
is not nothing hmm listen yeah I want a
certain kind of character I would like
to be able to crack jokes with me like
I'd well I do you understand my stupid
way of life and in the small little
things that kind of matter bro and
issues did might cost topics will go on
later on in this video we have issues in
my cost I am willing to go to to do that
challenge okay because are you telling
me and this question is for anyone in
the state are you telling me that even
if she's a virgin they're not going to
be like likewise big problems here
marriage you guys need
avoid together how kind of evil but
listen here for me is very easy if she
done what she done in the past and she
repented to a loss with halimbawa -
Hannah yeah and she comes to me and she
tells me listen this and this this has
happened in my past but now I'm like
this and this and this and this the
reason why you and I start speaking yeah
and this is what you saw on me so don't
judge me for my past judge me for now
lost on line with the hella does not
only forgive a person he adds to their
skill not in bad deeds not impugn --is--
meant yeah but in good deeds so how can
I have a different standard than my lord
how can I not try to be the best version
of myself I'm not saying it's easy but
why those people Haarlem love and what
I'm going to hold you there I'm gonna go
to Amman for you man you heard what
Julian said I'm brother Mohammed said as
well so - brother brother Mohammed
saying look I don't care she's not a
virgin to me it just matters about her
Dean and that's what
oh no care by fathers want us forgiving
her and only forgiving and turn the
bodies into goodies Who am I to come and
say I want a [ __ ] let's go to death so
not the Prophet so I said plans on let's
see we our opinion should be based on
the religion talking right the key tab
with this one yes yeah I lost parent I
said that they were not really believe
until they make view oh mama
the judge between them have no Harwich
with the last what you say they have no
enmity with regards to the ruling and
then test leemarie submit to it so what
I leave you a son
okay so let's come to the hadith of
Jabbar not a lot of the Awad very famous
hadith from which we can derive many
benefits but can also derive what the
ruling or permissibility is with regards
to desiring to marry a virgin okay okay
after the Battle of Tabuk no which was a
big expedition yeah
the army of the process Saddam was
returning back to Medina at the front of
the army you see Jabba driven up the lot
of the allah and young happy teenager
and his galloping Moira's horse eager to
enter into the city the processor looks
at ya jabbar how you in such a hurry in
a rush like you hold it down yeah jab it
looks to the message of some of our
audience and said yeah also why i am a
recently married man just after I got my
I to leave for the expedition I'm eager
to be with my wife yeah okay good he
inquires he's the teacher
did you marry you know a virgin yeah and
Jabbar says no resort of I married a
widow yeah
and this is really the agenda why did
you not marry a virgin so that you could
play with her and that she could play
with you
okay and the shorter of the hadith
explain that there is an intimate
connotation to what the person is
talking about an official ya jabbar not
be allowed aneesa's yellows lie you know
my father he became you know he died in
the Battle of mother she shot a lot and
I love the alive and he left behind
seven in one oration nine daughters yeah
and I didn't want to marry a woman who
would just be as young as them I don't
be able to take care of my sisters so I
married an older woman who could be like
a mother figure and so on and so forth
now the hadith goes on even further we
don't have many benefits about how our
husband and wife can be intimate with
each other but what I'm gonna take from
here is the fact that the prophecy don't
give preference to him marrying a virgin
now sisters please
won't that calm down I'm gonna explain a
little bit more okay but Jeremy speaking
the default position for a man when he's
looking for a woman he should look for a
virgin girl why because the messenger
sallallaahu adding to them give
preference to a virgin in this situation
so in light of that it is permissible
and totally okay for a brother to want
to marry a virgin it's his right as we
explained there could be many problems
psychologically speaking men have more
heater than women yeah so for a man to
know that his woman was once with
another guy and that other guy was its
first is think that will play in his
mind holding woman I'm so sure to get
closer but the one in the same that
happened was with a sister if it was a
guy hmm
wouldn't she be like okay about I don't
wanna is well yeah I don't necessarily I
mean no I know these exceptions and some
women yeah but then would be much of a
bigger problem yeah
yeah you let's not be around a bush it's
much more difficult for men because men
have that leader in them that women
don't men have that end of that
protective jealousy from her Hartman's
he's being fine
another man touring dealt with this do
something so neither hello there
whatever the reason is if the man wants
to marry a virgin yeah let him but pause
pause yeah we live in a society where a
lot of women unfortunately have lost
their virginity her armies so swordsmen
of course men without shadow they're not
losing them to women are they losing its
other men the point is not because of
this if every man makes it a requirement
that I will marry a virgin that is it
yeah then I think it's a bit unfair
because if every man did that yeah no
one will really get married because
let's just be real there's just not that
many virgins as they should be out there
yes I'm saying so if that said those who
really have a big problem with it and
for them it's like it has to be a virgin
yeah I you know for them it's
understandable is even understand so it
depends on the individual it depends
what I'm saying is like if it's like the
brother was saying right you man is
sky-high
okay I'm related she's gonna be able to
raise like who the next generation of
whatever and and and and and and and the
Imams that will take this this one when
kovitch really marry her right because
the one who narrate from which we take
the hadith to the passo sella Brava the
one who advised jab you know why did you
marry virgin himself symbolizing him
only married one version yeah he also
married many ones okay just I'm saying
okay so that shows you it's also
praiseworthy to marry or not virgin okay
right okay okay so basically let me ask
you something there so guys can somebody
like a guy that's going around and
stepped around done whatever they like
does he have a right to say I wanted
Myra virgin does he have that right of
course he has mommy does he have that
yeah it's not me to take rights all the
way okay what to give them
okay for me cross was your opinion was
it be recently I think it's some sort of
hypocritical if I imagine I got a tote
idea yeah and I'm then the Masjid and
handle a letter as a brother who's
interested in my
yes so it's me brother Mohammed I look
to get married okay
but yeah your daughter did she marry
already no priority okay but is she a
virgin
yeah and I asked him a key are you a
virgin yeah he says no I'm not yeah but
she needs to be I let him get lost okay
that's why okay well so like I said that
hey look here um like brother Mohammed
said it's not for us to take rights away
from people if a lot of Hannah were to
add are facilitated the demand has the
right and the capacity to choose if he
wants to bury a virgin or not
irrespective and that right is not
conditional to whether he's a virgin or
not okay then we can't take that right
away okay
now if that said you gave two examples
yes there is a man who sleeps around
we've made him in yes which they are
brothers an unknown you're listening in
for you meet these kind of brothers in a
regular basis right if sleep around with
the girls yeah but in early intervention
in Patel I when I marry marry me a
virgin
you my friend are fasiq you're a sinner
and know that in certain Iran lots of
hannover to either said that the belly
good woman the pure woman is for the
pure man and the filthy man is for the
filthy woman so that person is not come
as a true repented
all the women in that situation is wrong
so you will get what you deserve
don't think if you if Allah does give
you a virgin she's gonna be one shake
hard trust me a tea
yeah she might be a virgin down a pee
but up here she might be a oh yeah
now on that not on that note yeah right
I because I mentioned that idea that
that ayah yeah now a system I have
committed a sin in the past yeah I lost
a virginity and because she made robot
yeah she becomes pure uh that's was
always what she becomes pure okay she
also could get she get she she could get
a a virgin uh no problem yeah open pure
yeah whatever you something let's not go
too deep into it yeah and I think they
won't problem Rama's with pure as well
yeah much more autonomy your heart is
not it's not down there yeah stop down
there it's not limited to one thing your
heart okay okay slow your hearts up okay
all right okay fine I feel but I quickly
quickly okay
and so so look with that said yeah I
just want to give you an analogy
yeah you see the women have the right to
have a mouth yeah they can have whatever
it's wrong
yeah they're generally speaking this
it's not wise yeah for a woman to be
like I'm a [ __ ] ten thousand pound my
hair or 1 million pound matter yeah give
it to me or I won't get married I mean
you must be a really you know good
quality sister if you're my heart is
that minion pouch yeah
but Jamie speaking if you say that my my
hair is a million pound no one can come
to you and say no that's all right it's
her my gift you okay so you can
basically do what you want the same way
with the man if you I was doing all
right and I read good fine just I'm
saying but as I mentioned in balance now
I just want to show you one other hadith
right because I think in this day and
age we have to be very realistic yeah
and I said there are a lot of non virgin
people right from both genders yeah I
told you that the one who's giving us
the advice is saying it's more
preferable to marry a virgin himself did
a very virgins except for one yeah shout
out the el agua and our mother yeah do
you say I'm saying um I couldn't listen
to me the person said that women are
married for four things yeah this is
very misunderstood so listen to me all
you thirsty brothers they're married for
their wealth they married for their
family they married for their buffness
the chillness or in America as they say
the heart is and then they married for
their Dean the person said marry a
physician he didn't say marry her for he
say that these are for visas for which
people do marry women and he's saying
I'm telling you bundle looks yeah even
though you do take them into
consideration but easing that put it to
the side pop off to the side Brendan a
gentleman to the side
present a focus on her religion he
didn't say marry her for her hymen at
the end of the day although I know it's
not as simple as this but it is just a
bit of skin she did make tobin she
repented and she came back from it don't
let it be bigger than it is so and
that's really something beautiful yeah
you can create problems as you don't
look them into a proportion okay well
then run a saying that is really
powerful really powerful if you make a
big issue about something it will not
leave your mind we're sleeping in your
loan but if you are willing to put stuff
on the side and
you go back to the Kitab and soon and
you look always to the best things of
your wife yeah that's how you feel when
you are low yeah buddy I'm gonna pick
devil's advocate yeah so some a lot of
brothers they say look at the matter is
not with her being a virgin the matter
is not that the matter is like some of
them said you know what if she got
married and got divorced I wouldn't mind
of course it's not they're gonna play
Monopoly right she's not gonna be a
virgin but the fact that bathed what
they're seeing is for example it's not
about her not being a virgin the problem
is how do I know that she didn't sleep
with 10 guys 20 guys or 30 guys because
she might be lying to me should I come
see you know all it was just one guy I
made a mistake
and we have understood julia has said
that it's a hard thing for a man to
accept so a man's gonna be thinking in
his head this is my home state there was
advocate he can be thinking okay but how
do I know maybe you ain't stepped around
hydrophone they're coming to me and
telling me oh it is it was only one guy
what would rock me see that's quickly it
doesn't matter whatsoever oh okay
doesn't matter whatsoever as I told you
it is not that she did the deed what's
the problem is and it's not that the
deed itself would just like for me say
that I'm not interested anymore I'm
interested in this sister for reasons
many reasons but you're saying the the
urban diversion don't care about us mr
Dean
yeah no no listen what I'm generally
trying to get at is I wanted to do a
right this point so clearly to everyone
yeah I don't care it was one the fact
that she did it it's a problem yeah she
did Poobah yeah now she is the person
she is and that's the person who I want
as my wife doesn't matter how many times
she did that need no because it does not
take away from her status right now okay
Decker of Muhammad said yeah it's a
matter if she was the worst sinner and
she came with all of that he please
daddy
whatever he is dirty is filthy there's a
matter because a lot of panel data
setting on your ad when Latina layer de
Luna my Allah here on aha well a
octoroon enough silletti haram allahu
allah be lucky well is noone lost his
slaves are not those who
check and they are not those who murder
other than him and I said you can rest
assure his slaves are not those who do
zina what may yes a valley can yellow
cab
I said you any of these three things
Allah said I wish you mili ate them you
are a flower ah da boo yomel opium ity
accrue de fátima hana and on the day of
judgment or losses are multiplied the
punishment for them for fornicators
multiply it but then he says Allah
there's an exception to the fornicators
and the murderers far the ship in lament
tab except for the one who returns back
to me next whole bar comes back she she
turns around he turns a mentor by my no
I mean I'm a little sorry Han for Allah
EKU bad deal wahoo
say ye ah t him bassinet Allah says not
only woo I forgive her and him for the
sinner that they did but if they believe
in me after making Toba leave that sin
and then come with righteous actions I
will wipe the slate clean and forgive
them and in return of those hundred men
that she slept with and I will take the
100 men with of zina and replace it with
a that same weight of sin bring good
deeds so gently speaker he dodged the
question it don't matter how many men
she said as long as she may told her but
even then let's be balanced even though
it's fine she's clean she's a pure
person no a key if the man wants that
verge let him be let him be it's okay
acting on Instagram I just put that
we're doing this video and virginity and
their sisters out going crazy I'm only
gonna marry me
I'm virgin man right ok cuz you've got
that right as well but for example if
mr. Eddie dowel or Julian or Mohammed or
musa advance and behind the camera
whoever if D say you know what if they
say I know for me it's difficult would
you like to say forget difficulty I want
me of our merchants go man aside it's
just okay um okay like what kind of
awkward things there are a lot of
questions and also that I look here like
I want to marry virgin is one and like I
said before is your right sister you
know if you want a man a saloon now
chill right hundred percent you can go
ahead and you know ask with that I'm
going to cook and wrap up this is a last
question you're buying it might be other
questions we need to wrap up here okay
so can a brother ask a sister she's a
virgin or not and vice versa can a
sister ask a Bravo are you a virgin or
not and him can be like this year lap
say that if she lies what happens she
deceiving him is he receiving her if a
man the man says do I have the right to
ask yeah and or sister yeah of course
you do it's a condition said if you want
it to be a condition okay if you for you
it's a condition you have the right to
ask at the beginning okay all right you
should say no no the longer she okay the
the both partners are allowed to ask
each other yeah but can the other one
lie
no it's impermissible point if he makes
it in condition remember the marriage is
a contract so then allow to life of
course not
if a key but if they know it's gonna
break up the lab committee Bernard is a
matter pro if the marriage in marriage
is a contract you've based a contract
upon a false date okay the man k at the
end of the night when he realizes that
she he was lied to actually he can cause
the marriage to be ended up he cuz he
was deceived okay but my vice versa if
the woman was lied to you the same way
the brothers and sisters as you heard
from the brothers here initially you
guys have benefited as we know Islam
caters for everyone you want to marry a
virgin you have that right to you don't
want to obviously like I said and it's
better is if you can accept that and
take that on bottomless to your reward
is Wallace Montana
hope you guys have benefited please
share this with your friends and family
if you have benefited and may Allah's
mercy and blessings be upon you all also
if you are in a haram relationship
please please watch reality from part 1
part 9 part 10 and internal with the
permission of allah so allah you will
leave your boyfriend or girlfriend
whatever may be and get married
share this video assalamu alaikum
this yeah I mean to be honest what it is
is yeah yeah it's um sorry so basically
get the can answers question to do with
a few questions at the same time you got
you up very quickly quickly uh okay